SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOANNE STUBBE: Hi, everybody.
You're in 507, and if you
look at your syllabus,
you'll find one of the things in
the front page of your syllabus
is called a lexicon.
And I'd like to
introduce you to why
we've chosen to have a
lexicon for this course.
So if you look at this
particular slide or overhead,
this is what John is
going to teach you
this semester--
introductory metabolism.
The glycolysis pathway,
fatty acid biosynthesis,
fatty acid oxidation,
amino acid metabolism.
A complete jungle.
How are we ever going to learn
anything out of this mess?
Well, that's actually
exactly the point.
So what we're going to do over
the course of the semester
is convince you that
all of this mess
can be simplified to
10 basic reactions.
And those 10 basic reactions
are what's in the lexicon.
So it turns out
all of biochemistry
for primary metabolism
can be described
using 10 different sets of
reactions and your vitamin
bottle.
And so if you look at
your vitamin bottle,
what do you see?
Most of you probably
take vitamins.
You have vitamin B1, vitamin
B2, vitamin B3, vitamin B6,
vitamin B12.
All of those provide
enzymes the catalysts
for all the reactions in this
complex metabolic pathway
I showed you on
the previous slide.
They expand the
repertoire of reactions
that enzymes can
actually catalyze.
And so within the lexicon,
what we're going to show
you is the chemistry of actually
how these vitamins work.
So again, if we come
back to the lexicon,
we'll talk about how
carbon-carbon bonds are
made and broken, fatty acid
metabolism, sugar metabolism.
We'll talk about oxidation
reduction reactions
and the vitamins that are
used for that transformation.
We'll talk about the energy
storage and the energy currency
in the cell-- ATP, etc.
So what the lexicon
is meant to do
is be an aid when you
can't remember what
does oxidation and reduction?
You can go back to your
lexicon and look up
what are the redox
cofactors that
are involved in transformation.
And by practicing the
chemistry in the first part
of the semester of
all these reactions,
metabolism should be
very straightforward
in terms of all
the connectivities.
So hopefully what you will do
is look through your lexicon
tonight, see what
these reactions are,
and then keep it by your
side during the rest
of the semester.
And when you're having
trouble understanding
some chemical
transformation, you
can use the lexicon as a guide
to think about the chemical
transformations that
you'll be looking
at over the course
of the semester.